In Hong Kong, Typhoon Mangkhut is being called the "King of Storms..."
...after wreaking havoc through Hong Kong and parts of China.
In the US, Supreme Court justice nominee Brett Kavanaugh...
...has been accused of sexually assaulting a California psychology professor...
...when she and Kavanaugh were in high school.
In Rwanda, more than 2,000 prisoners have been pardoned...
...by Rwanda's President Paul Kagame.
Mexico commemorates twin anniversaries of earthquakes...
...that killed 350 people in 2017...
...and another that resulted in 10,000 fatalities in 1985.
Finally from Peru, President Martin Vizcarra of Peru...
...is threatening to dissolve the legislative branch...
...if Congress does not accept the proposal...
...to approve constitutional reforms to combat corruption.